what I literally randomly clicked on
this scroll down and it says troll
activity on YouTube is on the rice help
the Swedish guide PewDiePie and his bros
ksi toby captain speaking spring to get
rid of them doing paste is just kickin
GG piss me what what did this come from
what complete oh I thought it said just
kick out trolled but its YouTube troll
oh let's play a secret piece
how the [ __ ] did they know that that's
how it looks like we just have a stack
of cash underneath the television kick
him it all right we started have
CaptainSparklez
be getting this [ __ ] out of someone
sitting in front of a computer wearing a
wonderful dress by the way I got a say
brofist click anywhere to use bullet
likes by hitting fans and throw dislikes
at troll falcon lover xxx will take
troll high to the sky I had no idea
about this game I had no input
whatsoever and it's obviously PewDiePie
bait and it obviously worried cuz I
randomly stumble upon it but hey I'm not
complaining
I need games to play I hate I like games
bro they would use me in it what the
[ __ ] can't do that brofist
[ __ ] why do I suck so much I dig troll
click as fast as possible to dig patrol
and get more likes Brooke
Jamie's prank isn't gonna [ __ ] pickax
you can mention it is right keep your
brofist man can it make him migrant
dammit the point is to kill the troll
and while you kill the troll kill
earlier normal fans that's a great
message bro Chris
chill bro Fitz I never came this far
Carol captain's burgers go get ready so
you just gave these pickles brofist oh
my god this is the best how did i do so
[ __ ] well on this one
come on come on another breakfast yes
yes to breakfast
greatest moment of my life
yes good what is this what is this
the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] got a balloon Jesus Christ
it's [ __ ] amazing Oh
no Jess keep bro fisting bro keep them
kept this burger get this ruckus right
here Oh Oh take him on dig him up
dig him in take your time on stairs you
come on Gigi champion this is my high
score go high score ten percent yeah
baby [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you off to Sweden [ __ ] I unlocked
the key aside i lo que si oh my god
Jesus Christ
go kiss a nice kick breath first
this gave me soo bread that I don't even
put bread
case I breath go kiss a breath thanks
Cassandra
Jeff stinging them on there's a chance
there's one none of a million chance yes
I guess that lap well come on come on
we're so close
yes counter-strike Mike red boat my grip
the troll never dies Wow Wow yes I
I mean gifts biggest gifts
ah I can play stupid skis the audience
[ __ ] off audience Wow
brofist the audience audience kiss that
it's a boy Wow fat girl ever take the
charge in it what do i do what do I do
oh my god amazing I am so into this game
I never thought this is sad enemies
English steel today
I'm gonna meet Hakeem the troll thank
bro fisted while he's being smashed beat
the [ __ ] out of youtubers while he kills
a bunch of fans but if many counts them
it's over
and then he'll throw this knife that
damn game of the year that'll be that'll
be aa treat ality you defeated bad troll
that piece is back on the Internet
thanks Game Developers thank you
Game Developers I press that was a weird
[ __ ] afternoon I gotta say the weird
word we're living in but if you enjoyed
this episode or whatever the [ __ ] it was
leave a like it really helps out a lot
thank you both for being bros and do
what you do I really appreciate it and
thank you most of all for watching my
[ __ ] it's brofist for you as always stay
awesome
Wow